que puis-je faire pour vous signaler que
m je cherche le grand amour
vous cherchez une grande armure non non
ce que je veux c'est l'amour d'une femme
vous voulez le mur d'une ferme
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit je veux
faire humour aux comptes
je veux de l'amour je comprends je
voulais des rames en alliant trop passé
dieu je n'aime pas les tentacules pas
par votre essai à force de trop
travailler tu dois prendre des vacances
ne plus occuper des vacances des autres
et je sais comment arranger ça m'évite
s'il te plaît du mois où nous allons une
toise hier oh non non non non non non
non
allez il ya une chose à faire tu peux
faire de la plongée déguster des mets
délicats ou juste profiter de la vue
génial papa merci beaucoup
quelqu'un pourrait allumer un feu
d'artifice dans ton coeur si ce n'est
pas la croisière s'amuse franck salut la
compagnie je me présente
vous devez être le légendaire comte
dracula adouli bout la googlisation
mines eu quelques mots suffisent à un
homme pour briller aux yeux d'une femme
par son intelligence adouli blague ou
lydia sion minet
assurer chéri passe des vacances d'où tu
avais raison grand père valentim les
monstres sont écoeurants il ne se doute
pas de ce qui va leur arriver
[Musique]
tout se déroule comme prévu
quelque chose chez cette femme ne
m'inspire pas confiance ce plat est mort
tellement délicieux camille de l'aïe
dans le gotha molle ce n'est pas un
poison pour vous
[Musique]
c'était vous au nom bluebeam à vomir